Constantine great to see you here in
Croatia welcome to grantchester once
again but in 2022 uh in Paul in Poland I
think on Romania you have played already
first time uh how was it can you
remember can you tell a little bit just
amazing feeling I mean to play all these
great players just after pandemics so it
was just fantastic yes I mean and that
experience do you think it's going to
help you yeah for sure because then okay
I remember first first game I played
against aronia and I mean I was like
okay I'm playing this fantastic players
in this unique event because okay of
course I played them before but on
separate events let's see one game one
at a time and then it's different but to
play them all I mean one event it's it's
a one one thing one it's amazing yes and
here we're going to have a different
time control it's gonna be rabbit and
Blitz do you think you play better with
short time controls I think it depends a
lot of you know one's form I mean I
tried my best to let's say achieve let's
say top form now I will see how
yeah how did you manage to do so no I
took a special training camp or
something no I had some training camps
with my friends I played a lot of Rapids
and Blitz so yeah I saw also with you
today David gavril lesko from Romania
young player Grandmaster who also
participated in cranchester before
um is he your second here yeah his acts
as my second yeah what what do you think
he's going to do during this tournament
and is it really helpful to have a
second durian rapid and Blitz events I
think okay mostly most of the work he
did before I mean helping me up with
openings and playing some training games
but also here I mean I think uh it's
very good to have somebody for support
because it can be let's say you play
very fast and some sudden you know
result could be could go both ways and
if it goes let's see some unfortunate
way then it's good to have somebody
around you to lift you up that's for
sure do you think it's going to be also
a great experience for him yeah I think
yeah I mean he has also experience as a
player so also the I think it should be
also nice for him
um you're living in Romania and over the
years do you feel that chess is actually
booming now in Romania
it's fantastic I mean last of since back
in 21 I mean we got this amazing support
from you know from all these our
partners and especially dragon's family
it was just just amazing the support
we're getting now and now you have a
really strong team s
I mean we have reached report to have
booked on Deck we have chefchenko kiril
so I mean what are your goals now you
know for Olympia for European uh okay
Europe Olympia will be one year away but
I guess we should aim for getting a
medal I mean in a European team event I
mean we have I think we're starting top
six at least wow and actually what's
happening with youth chess maybe you can
tell a little bit about it uh you're
just okay I am not that familiar with I
mean they have their uh let's say their
program but I know they brought some
very experienced coaches like Ramesh
also I think captain of Romanian team
Evans okolov was working a lot of
youngsters so yeah you can also expect
some some talents coming up especially
if one is involved yes yes we know he's
yeah yeah of course results with
Uzbekistan team yeah so the last
question is simply like what are you
looking forward to achieving this event
I just want to you know to play my best
chess to enjoy all this fantastic event
with all these top players yeah thank
you Constantine thank you best of luck
thank you
foreign